[Music]
most people think about our as objects
that you you put something in a gallery
like a sculpture or painting but for us
our assistance our feeding systems it's
almost like a layer of magic on top of
the reality I would say that we are
artists that work with software and
hardware if we work with technology but
to make artistic expression he asked me
to work on the project with him and for
some reason he always asked me to work
on a project at a bar I personally love
things I can touch so I love working
with hardware I love it like tronics I
have a lot of patient with debug gating
like hardware problem and that is kind
of the contrary he is really good at
software and software debugging when
there's an integration coming in we both
are doing kind of what we like I really
want to find a way to visualize emotions
so other people can understand how a
person is feeling and to have some kind
of empathy if they can see the emotions
being visualized so this app that can
actually visualize your speech based on
the volume and how many words you speak
and how fast you speak it and it's
almost like a audio visualization and
turn into a mask that obscures your face
really weird stuff especially with the
face like cut parts of the face take the
eyes extend them out I'd really kind of
play with the face and then use that
almost as a kind of mask like take your
left in your right eye create a crown of
them around your head and then use that
to hide your identity we've been
experimenting a lot with space you and
using AR to put things in 3d space like
put images or video or sound and type
was a natural progression and those
experimentations what does it mean to
both words in space so weird type is an
AR app that you can install on your
phone and it allows you to write text
and then place that text in 3d space so
that you can write a message and you can
place it and as you move the type can
change or animate but it really is like
floating in the air MoMA land I have
just been just experimenting and playing
what they are making these weird you
know expressions in the studio and
posting them online it's so nice to
actually have something that we can give
to people that people can people can try
and they can have the same sort of joy
that we've been having so these
technologies are already out there face
tracking you know these computer vision
techniques it's machine learning
techniques they're out there and what
we're trying to do is appropriate them
and use them for artistic for creative
expression and also to suggest we can
use them in completely different ways in
ways that governments are not intending
and companies are not intending but
artists can sort of suggest different
possible futures
[Music]